okay so
the when i come at someone in aikido and
i'm doing this number right the the the
stupid aikido zombie right which is this
okay this is not an effective attack
all right mike's really strong
he can probably hold off my initial
impact and then we're fighting right
okay what i want to do so i take a
couple steps in i want to explode into
the target so i want to take a couple
steps boom and i want to hit him back
okay so i want to put my center through
his the idea what i'm trying to do is
get rid of him right so coming in boom
okay so i'm gonna take a couple steps in
from the chest i'm gonna explode just
like in football i'm gonna make a like a
maybe a 45 degree angle to the path and
push boom straight into it i'm trying to
explode i want to knock him back that's
why i'm even doing this right
you wanna
all right i'm going for it
sorry
when you come though everything